- I'm gonna keep my
introductory comments very brief
so we can get straight into the panel.
But I just wanted to say a word or two
about how this panel came about.
Basically this panel emerged
because I have a very messy desk.
I've been accumulating all
these books on Vietnam studies
in Southeast Asian Studies.
And one day as these books are piling up
on my desk, I noticed
an accidental pattern
pop out from the spines of the books
that are piled up in my quarantine office,
also known here in the Harms
family as the dinner table.
And I noticed in this pattern
that I was the proud owner
of three recently published books
all on the subject of
militarized landscapes
of the Indochina conflicts.
And they were based on
research in Laos, Vietnam,
and Cambodia.
And I immediately wondered,
when I saw this pattern emerge,
I wondered if the authors
were in conversation
with each other.
So then a few emails later,
I wrote to the authors and I wondered
if they were in conversation.
And they said they'd love to be.
So all of a sudden we had a panel.
And now here we are with a crowd.
Actually, let me see we
have a crowd of 45 people
that emerged out of just
this mess on my desk.
So let me just take a moment
to introduce the speakers.
And I think just by
naming them and the titles
of their books, you can
imagine the connections
that I think will be emerging
from today's discussion.
First is David Biggs.
He's a professor of
history at UC Riverside
he is the author of "Footprints of War,
Militarized Landscapes in Vietnam,"
published by the University
of Washington press, in 2018.
Next is Jonathan Padwe.
He's an associate
professor of anthropology
at the University of Hawaii Manoa.
His book is called "Disturbed
Forest Fragmented Memories
Jarai and Other Lives in
the Cambodian Highlands,"
which was also published by
the University of Washington
press in 2020.
And we also have Leah
Zani an anthropologist,
author and poet who holds a PhD
from UC Irvine,
and who is the author of "Bomb Children.
Life in the Former Battlefields of Laos,"
published by Duke
University Press in 2019.
As you can see the titles of these books
immediately form a pattern.
So I won't go into any detail
about what the goal of
today's discussion is, really,
the main goal is to bring
these authors into conversation
with each other.
So the panel is designed
specifically to allow the authors
to engage in an open discussion.
And I'll serve as the moderator,
but I'm hoping that the
panel will really evolve
into an open discussion
between the authors
and all the audience members.
So to get us started, I'll
start with two questions.
The first question will be to ask them
in five minutes or less just to tell us
as an audience especially for those of you
who haven't read the books yet.
Just give a sense of what the books
are about what the main argument is there,
any innovations they feel are in it?
And then my second question,
after they've all talked
about the kind of main project
of the book will be to ask each of them
to pick a kind of favorite
passage of the book.
One of the things that's
really significant about all
of these books is the
way they've attended,
not only to the topic of
militarized landscapes,
but to the art and practice of writing.
So I thought it'd be really great
to kind of treat this a
little bit like a miniature
book reading as well.
So that will be my second question.
And then after that,
that should probably take about 30 minutes
to do all of those,
and then I'll open it up to questions
from the open Zoom audience.
So let me turn to the first speaker,
David Biggs tell us David
in five minutes or less,
what is your book about?
And what do you see as the
main argument for innovation?
- Well, thanks, Erik, and
colleagues, panelists,
everybody for coming.
It's really a pleasure
to be here in this forum.
This forum is better than no
forum at all. (David laughing)
And Erik, I wonder if you can
just hit play on this video,
and I'll use it to talk
about the first part
and then the other slides
are for the second part.
So this is a clip from
WGBH's Vietnam series.
It was filmed in 1981.
On the road from the Hue
Phu Bai airport into Hue,
and it is a panorama of
what used to be camp Eagle,
this was 101st airborne divisions camp
really operated from 1968 to 72.
And what you're seeing is six years later,
the residual detritus and
debris that's left from this.
And the US forces pulled
out in about one month
they went from 15,000 troops
to about 400 caretakers.
And what interests me in
this project on militarized
landscape is really
thinking about the scale
of the military occupation in Vietnam.
We hear a lot about the bombing,
intense bombing in a very small area.
But the question I had is really
how does the country
recover from this kind
of military footprint?
And that's where the term
footprints of war comes from.
It's sort of thinking about that.
And theoretically, I'm very much inspired
by a kind of dialectical
approach to military footprints
and militarization.
And I found the work of Andrea Fab
who is completely incomprehensible,
but wonderful nonetheless,
very interesting,
and that he talks about his native Paris.
And he talks about a certain
dialectic and urban spaces
between representational
spaces, spaces of practice,
sort of physical creations,
and how these interact.
And he's basically talking
about a certain agency of space.
And I tried to apply that in my book
to militarize spaces.
And the sort of question
that really drives this book
is thinking about militarized
spaces as having a kind
of agency on development on post war.
But as I began to study these places,
I began to realize that, in fact,
these same military spaces
had been occupied before
and they have been occupied
actually by military forces
for several centuries.
So the book that unfolds
is really a long history
of militarization.
It's contextualizing
the American occupation,
in a much longer dialogue that
Vietnamese people have had
with different military
forces in these landscapes.
And so I use landscape as
a kind of analytical lens
to look at these
dialectical relationships.
So that's kind of what
I'm trying to do there.
- Great, thanks David.
Leah, I ask if you can go next.
Answer the same question,
what is your book about?
And what do you think are
some of your main innovations,
and allow me just to
unshare the screen briefly?
- Well, I think any book
has multiple origins.
But one origin story for this book
that I'd like to share with you today
has to do with these jars of bits of bombs
that I brought back from my field studies
with explosive clearance teams.
And at first I started
collecting these by accident,
I would just find them
when I was out walking
with bomb technicians.
And they would say, "oh,
that's a bit of a bomb,"
and then they would
examine it and make sure
it wasn't explosive.
And then I was allowed to take it home
(Leah laughing) with me if I wanted to.
So I started collecting
these sort of by accident.
But it slowly became this
kind of paranoid process,
where every time I saw a
bit of metal on the ground,
I would think to myself,
is that part of a bomb.
And there was one time when I was out
with a bomb technician in a village.
And we found this piece of metal here,
which you can't quite see,
but I'll tell you about it in my story.
I found this piece of metal in a village.
And she looks at it and she says,
"oh, this is part of a rocket."
And she hands it to me,
and she says "you can keep it."
And as I was looking
at this piece of metal,
I became suspicious because I didn't think
it was actually part of a bomb.
But she had just told me that it was
and so I kept on kind of
fiddling with this item,
and asking other people to look at it,
and eventually realizing that
it wasn't part of a rocket.
It was part of a motorcycle engine.
And so I saved it in my bomb collection,
even though it's not part
of a bomb, (Leah laughing)
as a reminder, that it's
really easy to mistake the war
like the most important
or most visible thing
that's happening in these battlefields.
But that's often not the case
that we have to pay
attention to the daily lives
that are being built
on top of or alongside
these remains of war,
like what David just showed us
in those compelling archival footage.
And so I kept that piece
of a motorcycle engine
to remind myself to really honor
and pay attention to
the lives of the people
that are currently living
in these old battlefields
and to not let the war
overshadow my senses.
And so the book in a way is kind
of a larger response to that.
What seems to me to be a kind
of ethical humanist impulse
to really respect the lives of the people
that are currently living in these zones.
And I developed this idea of parallelism,
that it's not that one is
more important than the other,
but that these two experiences one of war
and one of everyday life
need to be treated side by
side and given equal relevance
in an anthropological
or historical analysis.
And that's harder to do than it sounds.
And the book is a kind of
experimental ethnography
of what that might look like in practice.
Yes, and so I look forward
to sharing a little exert later
of what I imagined that
looking like in practice,
when we get to that, thank you.
- Great, thank you, Leah.
I'm gonna turn it over to Jonathan,
to talk briefly about
what he sees his book
being about and what he sees
as the main contribution.
Jonathan also asked me to share a screen.
So one moment as I do that.
Jonathan, can you see the slide?
- I can see it.
I think we all can.
- [Eric] Great.
- Yeah so this picture is just to give you
a little bit of geographical grounding
for where the work for
this book took place.
And this is in the kind of
crook of the say, Sand River,
right where the Vietnam
border is with Cambodia.
So the villages that I was working in
are right inside of that border.
You can switch forward there, Eric,
I just wanted to sort of locate us.
But then this next image is just for you
to see a landscape that's
a swidden landscape
up in the hills of Cambodia.
And you can immediately
see that there's a story
of living in the land
that the swidden process,
this process of burning,
clearing, planting,
plots of farmland creates
in the landscape itself,
there's a history of living
and it's a moving history
as the swidden field itself sort of moves
across the landscape.
The book, "Disturbed
Forests, Fragmented Memories"
is an effort to narrate a series
of historical conjectures
that the Jarai people
of Northeast Cambodia have experienced,
from their perspective,
and from the perspective
of the landscape itself.
The idea is that the
landscape tells stories
certainly for the Jarai people,
when you are hanging out with them
and talking about history,
talking about the past.
It is always in reference to
the places that they live,
the places that historical
events have taken place,
and the forests, the rivers,
the components of the landscape itself,
play a role often,
and the spirits that inhabit these places
play a role in these stories.
They shape the stories
they are, in a way agentive
they're actors in these stories.
And the thrust of the book,
the idea is that these stories provide
new insights into regional
and world history,
that these are subaltern
histories that reimagine
and often contradict
conventional narratives
about the experience of
colonialism, for example,
about the Vietnam War
about the Cambodian genocide.
And I note in the book
that E.P. Thompson called
"This Kind of Account History From Below."
And I make the point that this
is elevationally inaccurate
in the case of the Jarai
since they are highlanders,
and that we should call these histories
from the hills instead.
There's a theory of landscape
underlying the approach in the book.
The landscapes are both
observed and lived in
and they bring together at
least three fields of inquiry
that have been important to
anthropologists and historians
and geographers, ecology, representation
and materiality, right.
So by focusing on landscape,
we're able to look at the actual ecology
that people live in,
and this could be in an urban setting
as well as in a setting
like the Jarai hill country.
There's a representational
dimension to landscape,
landscapes are imbued with
meanings through the processes
of being lived in.
And at the same time,
there's an opening here
for understanding them
in the materiality of the landscape,
and also in a way that it is
active in the social world
of the people who inhabit it.
There's one more point it was interesting,
I was trying to find the point
where I must have written
this down in the introduction
of my book, the role of
thinking with conjuncture
in putting together an
understanding of how we might
look at these landscapes
of all of this region.
And I realized, of course,
that I just completely
subsumed this critical point
within myself and it comes
out in all of the different
pieces of the book,
but it's never explicit.
And this is this notion
I was really interested in the way
that scholars like Tania Li,
talks about the conjunctural analysis
in her book "Land's End."
And other scholars also, Nancy
Palooza has a great article
that uses the concept of
conjuncture as an insight
as a way of getting insight
into historical processes.
And of course, they're
borrowing from Stuart Hall
and Doreen Massey and others.
And the idea here is that
people live in conversation
with the landscape that they inhabit
that they are constantly
interacting with it.
And those interactions
are shaped by the set
of political and economic
forces that are operating
in a given moment.
And these change over time, very abruptly.
So even though it may
seem like there's this
sort of story of resilience,
with farming up in the hills,
when you really talk to people up there
about what their experience has been
of the past,
you see that they've changed
their agricultural system
and their way of interacting
with their environment.
Or they've had it changed
on them very rapidly
over the course of these
different historical periods.
So that what they were doing
during the colonial period,
and their relationship with the landscape
had salient features during say the moment
from 1952 or three, whenever
it was that Cambodia
gained independence.
It changes again with the arrival
of the Khmer Rouge, et cetera, right.
And it's not a surprise
that the landscape then
records and takes on
elements of this history
that it expresses the
historical conjuncture
that it is formed during and
these expressions live on
after that moment has
passed and serve as ways
into the past.
But only in a partial way, right?
Because the ecologies are
constantly being reworked.
So this is this notion of the disturbance,
but also the disturbed force
and fragmented histories
that these histories are never complete.
They're always partial.
So I'll leave it at that.
- Fantastic, Jonathan.
So thanks to all three of you for sharing
a kind of introductory window
into these three fantastic manuscripts.
A couple of things.
Later, I will wanna ask you a question
about this idea of reading the landscape
as a historical archive,
cause I think that's
something that all three
of you can talk about.
But I'll save that question for later.
I wanna turn to something
that Leah mentioned
in passing when she was
introducing her book.
She used the term
ethical humanist impulse.
And one of the things that's very evident
in all three of your
books is a deep attention
to the writerly practice,
narrative and storytelling.
And bringing in the story of a landscape
with actual narrative
strategies in the writing
of your text themselves.
Which I see is entangled with
that ethical humanist impulse.
So what I'd like to do
now is ask each of you
to pick a passage or a story,
you can either read from the book
or retell a story, in your own
words from the book itself.
As a way to kind of give a window
to our audience into your approach,
your writerly approach to addressing this.
I'll start with Leah.
- Thank you, Eric.
Well the section I wanna
share with with you today
is the opening section of the book.
Which is a place where I
try to lay out narratively
this concept of parallelism
and what it looks like
in the ethnographic record.
And then I'll share a poem
that I wrote based off
of a similar encounter.
"The fruit eaters.
Before becoming a bomb technician,
an interlocutor of mine served as a monk
for seven years at a
Theravada Buddhist temple
in Vientiane in the capital of Laos.
After his work day at the office
of an explosives clearance operator
that is hosting my research,
he invites me to ride
with him on his motorbike
to visit his former temple Wat Sokpaulang
on the outskirts of town.
Wat Sokpaulang is a forest
temple originally situated
in the jungle outside the city walls,
though in recent decades,
it has been encompassed by urban sprawl.
The temple maintains
expansive forested grounds
circumnavigated by a white gilded wall.
Leaving our motorbike against
the wall we enter by foot
under a large lavishly painted archway
of entwined dragons.
As we cross into the forest and interior
the sound of the nearby thoroughfare
is smothered by vestigial forest preserved
within the temple grounds and underbrush
of flowering ginger and medicinal herbs.
Plus large trees whose
trunks host pale lichens,
wax leaved bromeliads,
ferns and trailing gray lianas.
When we arrive at the
central plaza next to the Sim
the most sacred central building,
a ceremony of cremation is underway.
The relatives and guests have left
only two silent novices remain
to attend the giant kalm.
They kindle the fire with long sticks
producing snapping crackles
that seem only to deepen the silence
in the plaza.
The air is diffused with blue smoke
and the thick smell of incense.
The coffin has already collapsed
upon itself and the body
is no longer visible within the flames.
Wreaths and other flowering
decorations smoke their green
moisture resisting the cremation.
We stay at the border of the plaza
and watch the flame
slowly diminish the corpse
and the flowers.
In this quiet zone of mortal reflection,
my companion tells me a strange,
brief war story he heard
while he was a monk
at this temple.
He told this story in the present tense
as he first heard it,
and as I tell it here.
Two American soldiers
are flying a helicopter
low over the jungles of Laos,
scouting for villages during
the Vietnam American war.
They are looking for
possible communist hideouts
sites where rebels built camps
or were hosted by existing villages.
Skimming the tree tops one
soldier sees very clearly
a village below.
Grass huts on stilts,
dirt worn paths through the green fields,
people walking with baskets of fruit
strapped to their backs.
He signals a landing nearby but
once they are on the ground,
there is no village to be found.
After giving up the search
and reboarding their helicopter,
the two soldiers keep watch
out of the vehicle's windows.
Neither one sees a village,
the village and its
inhabitants disappeared.
In response to my perplexed expression,
my interlocutor explains,
there are worlds around us
that we can't see full of people
who are right and honest
and only eat fruit.
They never kill anything.
These worlds exist parallel
to the present realm,
other realms other heavens and hells.
My interlocutor spreads his arms wide
and sweeps them around
while wriggling his fingers
as if to touch the stuff
of these many worlds
all around us invisible.
The world that the soldiers
glimpsed in the war story
is known as the realm of the fruit eaters.
It is a special paradise
inhabited by merit field beings
who never kill anything
to sustain themselves.
They only eat fruit that has
fallen freely from wild trees.
This kind of food is free
from the negative karma
of slaughtering animals
or destroying plants.
It is a realm without butchers,
meat eaters, murderers,
executioners or soldiers.
As a result of the virtuous habits
of the residents,
the realm of the fruit eaters is peaceful
and all the beings who reside
there are healthy and happy.
Only especially morally correct beings
are reincarnated as fruit eaters.
By comparison, the immoral
actions of the inhabitants
of our world are creating a state
of near perpetual war,
violence and suffering.
My interlocutor explains
that the Vietnam American War
made the boundaries between
these parallel worlds
porous and so in the midst of war,
one American soldier
glimpses allow paradise
free of violence."
So that's the opening of my book,
written in the present tense,
in the same tense that
my companion told me
this war story.
And later on, I was
reminded of the fruit eaters
while doing field work with
a bomb clearance squad.
When one of the technicians told me
that she remembered the
different kinds of bombs
because they all look like
different kinds of fruit.
And she had fruit names for all
of the different kinds of bombs.
And in response to that,
I wrote a poem called "The Fruit Eaters,"
which I'll also share with you.
"The exceedingly virtuous eat only fruit
that freely falls without
knowledge of death.
She forges from the forest,
cucumber bombs, guava bombs,
bael bombs, pineapple bombs, melon bombs.
"Sometimes I wonder if they are supposed
to look like fruit
so that we will pick them up."
She holds a yellow bomb
the size of her fist
with fins, like the blades of pineapples."
Thank you.
- Thank you, Leah.
I hesitate to interrupt.
I want everyone to just pause
on the sound of that final poem.
Now let's take a moment
and turn over to Jonathan.
Jonathan, did you want me
to share your slides again?
I know you had a few more,
maybe for this scene.
- You know we talked about this.
I think it's fine not to.
I thought if people were sharing slides,
I'd share slides but no worries.
Okay, I'm gonna read just a section
from it's my turn yeah, Eric.
So sorry, I'll just read a section
from the book called "Forest of the Dead."
During this visit to
my friend Twic's farm,
just to note I referred to him as Jiang
as a form of address and
this reflects an alliance
that we've consecrated
between the two of us so.
"I went to visit Kasoa Twic
at his farm on the Yabla
to the east of the village
where the mountains of Vietnam loom off
in the distance.
Twic and his neighbors
have cut their fields
from a broad expansive forest.
Here the farmland slopes gradually up
from the stream, and
ends in a fringe of trees
and scrub at the top of the ridge.
Between the stream and the forests edge
all has been cleared and planted,
low lying cashews at the bottom
of the hill, sesame, tobacco,
maize and rice in the more
recently created fields
towards the top.
All has been cleared that is,
except for a shock of trees
that jets out in the midst
of Twic's farm field,
a 400 square foot stand
of forest in the middle
of acres of farmland.
The day I arrived, I found
Twic working the edges
of that anomalous cluster of trees.
He stood shirtless and covered in sweat,
a bush knife in his hand,
his torso streaked black
where the charred branches
he carried had marked him.
He was clearing brush from
the edge of the corpse
removing it to small piles
that he had set alight,
and as those piles burned all around,
he assessed the corpses
edge inside, exasperated,
or perhaps it was a kind
of mock exasperation.
This was common with
Twic that he would laugh
about his predicament.
Not with irony,
but with complete sincerity.
'Oh, Jiang," I addressed
him as I walked up.
He smiled, happy to see me.
"You look frustrated, what's the matter?"
He sighed again,
still smiling as he
looked from burning piles
to the shaggy forest.
"The dead", he said.
"It's the dead Jiang."
It's not just the spirits known as Yang,
who inhabit the forests
of the Northeast hills
but also a bow the dead who live there.
Villages produce dead people,
and the living bury the dead
in the forest at the villages edge.
There upon those forests
may no longer be cut,
they must be left to grow freely.
This is why one finds funerary statues
under the tallest patches of forest
in areas where villages once stood.
When a village site is abandoned,
the village burial ground
becomes its own forest type,
a forest of the dead, a glide and fowl.
This is an ecological
formation and a social world
at the same time,
a forest animated not just by memory,
but by human presences too.
It was just such a socio
ecological formation that Twic
was dealing with here in the middle
of his agricultural lands
where the forest of the dead
was shading out his
crops and taking up space
he might otherwise use for farming.
Twic he told me there
were jars and statues
and tombs inside the
darkness under those trees.
He invited me to enter the corpse
and poke around no harm would come to me.
So I did just passed the
tangled edge where binds
and shrubbery crowded the light,
I found a decaying statue that resembled
the antenna of an insect
or perhaps elephant tusks.
A familiar funerary form, and
large shreds of ceramic jars
emerging from the ground where
they had once been placed
at the head of a tomb.
It was a graveyard, but who's?"
So the intervening couple of pages Twic
and his wife, Mon, tell me the story
of whose graves those are.
And this is the story of this village
from Pleiku province in Vietnam,
which had come across
the river to Cambodia
to flee the rolling
thunder bombing campaign
and this series of bombings
that was taking place
in just across the river at that time.
And so what happens is that this village
actually seeks shelter with
the villagers of Tankahuan,
who they have some relations
with some kin relations.
And they're granted this place to come
and do their farming.
But at this moment,
the American bombing
campaign begins in Cambodia,
and a bomb is dropped on the settlement
killing everybody in the settlement.
And then, some of the
relatives came across
and the survivors, what
people were able to find
were buried in the site.
And I just wanted to finish up here
with a couple more lines
of where this winds up
because I think you can see a little bit
of how the history is worked
into the lived experience
of the landscape.
"The scene I encountered
in Twic's field illustrates
how the forest as forests and
as socio ecological formation
acts upon the world.
In his appraisal of the
edge of the Galayatal
in his swidden field Twic
used his capabilities
as a farmer and as a
Jarai person to consider
how he should treat the
small cluster of trees.
It would have been more
efficient from the perspective
of agricultural productivity
to do away completely
with the tangled patch
of forest and graves.
But Twic did not conceive of
the situation in these terms.
Rather, he faced a dilemma
of what should be burned
and what should be left and
where the edge should be,
and how thoroughly he
should intervene to balance
a set of objectives and requirements
as he understood them.
There were aesthetic as well
as moral questions involved,
the landscape should look a certain way.
It should include certain
plants arranged appropriately
in relation to each other.
The corpse was replete with memory
and meaning it had a
representational force
that acted upon Twic.
But it was also animated by the presence
of vietaw, the dead who
resided in the forest
and who required respect.
Finally, it was also very much alive,
it was growing as it had
been since the victims
of the American bomb had been buried
in the spot.
Likewise, of course Twic's swidden field
was itself alive both
with crops he had planted
and with incidental species
that were either desired or not desired,
based on their usefulness.
And all the plants themselves furthermore,
possessed pungat what we might call souls,
and thus, at the very least,
must be understood to
have a certain vitality.
That is, in a way comparable
with that of humans,
who also, of course, also have pungat.
The multiple vital
presences with which Twic
was necessarily required to negotiate
make up the landscape,
not so much a productivity
problem to be solved as
a set of relationships
to be managed and attended to."
So it goes on from there.
- Thank you, Jonathan.
It's amazing to hear ethnography read.
It's something we often
don't give ourselves
the opportunity to do.
And that's quite powerful
ethnography written there.
Let me turn it over to David Biggs
for the last section of this.
And then after that,
I just wanna encourage people
to start formulating questions,
cause we'll open it up
to the audience for questions after that.
Go ahead, David.
- Thanks, Eric.
And, for mine if you can share the screen,
I've got a slide the third slide there.
It'd be good.
It'll help people understand where we are.
So I'm gonna read a passage.
I don't know, it's not as ethnographic.
So I hope you'll bear with me,
but it's a very important story
in the sense for, one before that.
So it's a very important
story for really reading
very famous military events.
And I think everybody on
the call knows that in 1968,
the Tet Offensive, the
Battle of Hue was this sort
of surprise attack on the city of Hue.
It's often retold in
so many different ways,
so many different movies,
I think, full metal jacket and all
these other Hollywood stories.
All Americans know the story.
And what's so amazing to
me is that they don't know
that this wasn't the first
Tet Offensive in Hue.
In fact, this was the
second or even the third
in a sense, and that French
troops land on these beaches
in 1883 but that's in the summer.
But I'm gonna tell you a story,
because I think it's very
important when we talk
about militarization to work
against presentist bias.
And especially writing in English
most Anglophone readers are very familiar
with the most recent war,
but we have a tendency to forget
about the earlier layers.
And again, if we talk about the agency
of militarized landscapes,
in a sense militarization
as a set of processes
from one era bleeds into subsequent eras.
So I wanna read this section from my book
in chapter three,
about the first Tet Offensive.
And I wanna read it in part
so you might understand
why it was, how it was
that two battalions of soldiers were able
to secretly put themselves in
the city and rise up in 1968.
And I think when you have
this first Tet Offensive,
it might give you some context, right.
"So fighting between Viet
Minh and French forces began
on December 19 1946, in Hue Fau.
And a destructive French naval
invasion at Hue commenced a month later
sparing thousands of
young people to retreat
from lowland defences
to the tactical zones.
In the months leading up to the invasion,
the Viet Minh urged its
followers to dig tunnels,
trenches and barricades.
In the city of Hue in nearby villages,
several thousand youth
dug defensive positions,
with bomb shelters and tunnels.
Upon receiving word about
the fighting at Hue Fang
Vietnam units in Hue blew all the bridges
along Highway One.
The admin troops in Hue
attacked about 800 outnumbered
but well armed French
troops at the marine hotel,
and other government buildings
in the French quarter.
Unlike the naval assault in 1883,
this military landing
met fierce resistance
from the landing beaches
to the streets of Hue.
Once just five days before the start
of the Lunar New Year,
this 1947 Tet Offensive
resulted in high numbers
of civilian casualties and left sections
of the town in ruins.
French Marines, most of
them from French Africa,
brought naval artillery and heavy weapons
against lightly armed but again Viet Minh.
Viet Minh forces had
governed Hue for over a year
after the August revolution
and even after the return
of French soldiers they
commanded a military regiment
and enjoyed strong
support in the villages.
Their units engaged French
forces invading by sea
at two inlands Tu Hien and Thuon An.
French forces landed on the
beach at SantoKai casualties.
One group a few thousand
troops with armored cars
loaded on American made
military landing craft surplus
after world war two unloaded at the banks
of the lagoon at Truoi
within a few hundred meters
of Highway One.
The other group landed at Tu Hien beach
with armored vehicles to
attack Hue from the north.
In contrast to the French
naval landing in 1883,
the forces in 1947 met
sustained resistance
from the beach to the city.
The southern group required 19
days to travel 30 kilometers
on Highway One from Truoi before meeting
the other group in Hue.
From Hue and Phu Bai French
forces spent the next month
reoccupying key military installations
finding them emptied with
all supplies removed.
As the French troops secured
positions along Highway one,
they destroyed village communal houses
at Da Le and Phu Bai
and they set up command posts
at some of the region's most sacred sites.
One of them was Nam Dong pavilion
on the southern edge of Hue.
Nam Dong included pine
gross and a pavilion
that hosted the annual
rights the Emperor performed
to bring prosperity and good harvest
to the kingdom.
The profaning of the
site with French troops
and military equipment,
especially bombs gave a clear visual sign
of the French position
vis-a- vis the recently
advocated head of state Valdai.
On the edge of the French Quarter
in the deforested spaces of Nan Zhau
the French military established
its Nodanam Hue sector."
So this is an example of a symbolic attack
on this landscape.
"After French forces broke
the Viet Minh defense
Viet Minh units retreated
to tactical zones.
Over the next several
years this move up hill
Zoo to facilitated profound territorial
and personal transformations,
especially for thousands
of Vietnamese youth.
The political and military leaders
of the Viet Minh had regroup
with their families at Hoa Mi for more
than a year since 1946.
The Drun Gavan regimens, three
battalions retreated here
and formed a company of commandos
to continue guerrilla
missions into the city.
After the French invasion
in the summer of 1947,
more army units and larger
communities so soldiers
and their families continued the Exodus,
expanding tunnel networks
into the mountains
and digging bunkers
and underground caches.
The province committee anticipated
that French occupation
forces would force youths
in the lowlands
to serve with the occupation military.
So it built tactical zones
as spaces for removing young men
from their mid teens to late 30s
from villages along Highway one.
They established routes of communication,
trails and secret codes
to guide youth volunteers
into the war zones,
opening paths for escape,
and for guerrilla teams to return."
And so those red dots you
see those are the first four
of those tactical zones that
were created on those rivers.
"While most histories focus
on the tactical elements
of these zones, a
hometwee district account
of the resistance capture
some glimpses of the tolls
on families in occupied villages
whose sons and daughters had gone up hill.
Resistant zones were
difficult places to survive
even without enemy attacks.
Mosquitoes carried malaria
and Viet Minh field hospitals
were lucky to have quinine
as a preventative medicine.
Young women with limited
training as nurses
regularly risked search
detention and torture
for carrying medicine
from towns such as Hue
into these rebels areas.
One doctor left a
prosperous practice in Hue
to carry medical supplies
to the field hospital
at the Khe Trai base.
The tactical zones foster
deep emotional connections
linking people from
different lowland villages
with each camp.
A district history describes
this yearning for relatives,
"the tactical zone was
a place of much longing,
excitement for reunions
and deep compassion.
Here was the basis for understanding
the preciousness of life.
In the afternoon, the people of Fu Vong
and Hue Twi districts
look from their homes
in the countryside to the
tactical zones in the hills,
remembering those working there
in service, transport,
communication, logistics,
remembering their first trips
into the tactical zones."
As the resistance
continued for seven years,
these emotional ties in
the traffic in and out
of the region, help
forged new trails and webs
of local networks,
through which the Viet
Minh national vision
extended across more of the
central coast, rugged terrain.
And now, Eric, if you can go
to the next slide.
Real quick.
Yeah.
So this is a close up
of that place Hoa My.
And the point I'm trying to make here
is that these earlier layer
of military conflict,
it wasn't just tactical
and moving on the land,
but it actually created
new social relationships.
And it created new interactions,
new symbolic and connections
with this landscape.
You see in the upper
right corner of this map
on the right, that's
highway one and the railroad
just north of Hue.
That's the street Wie Troi
that Bernard Fall writes about.
And this is a place called Hoa My.
And what's so interesting,
if you read this map closely,
you can see the names of the hilltops
to the right.
And the hilltops to the
right have all been cleared.
They have an in, the letter in means Nui.
And if you look to the left, however,
this is another French map.
This is a topographic map,
drawn and then reproduced in 1952
by the US Army mapping
service for the French.
You see the UTM grid,
this purple grid that's overlaid.
That's a world war two
military grid system
the Americans use and the allies use
and that was used for calling
in bombing coordinates.
But what's really interesting
are the ridge names on the left.
You see a transition from the word Nui
to a word Gulp,
and a word dumb and gulm signify,
not ethnically Vietnamese hilltops.
And so this gateway,
that is an important tactical
zone for the Viet Minh youth
is also a really important
cultural gateway.
It's the place in which
so many of these youth
entered into these trails
that then move further west
and north up to the
battle zones in the north
of Vietnam during the
French Indochina War.
And so there's a very important kind
of spatial practice that
is happening in 1947
for these youth.
Many of them get relocated after 1954
as combatants to Tanwar.
They become part of some
Hue area central Vietnamese
regiments in the People's Army of Vietnam.
And again, what's
interesting is that by 1966,
some of these regimental
units are back in this area.
And so one of the points I try and make
in my book is that if
we take a deeper study
of militarization in these
particularly militarized spaces,
we can better understand
how different groups
of combatants move through these spaces
and how they understand them.
And I think that applies
not just to Vietnam,
it applies to Afghanistan,
to Iraq and to desert areas
and other parts of the world.
And I think it's that presenters bias
that is really missing.
I do have one last story to share.
But I'm not sure if I have time.
Eric.
- David, you can share your story.
- Okay, thanks.
It's towards the end of the book.
And it's this final
kind of epilogue chapter
if you can go to the next slide.
Oh, and I'll say one more thing
about this place Hoa My.
So Hoa My was so symbolically
important for the Viet Minh.
It was also very symbolically important
for the Hue family, the mode Enzian family
and his family.
That when they got American
aid money to develop
these new strategic Hamlet's
and things like that,
the first place they picked to send
the bulldozers was Hoa My.
They wanted to relocate people there
not because it was a great
place for agriculture,
but because symbolically
it was a way to level
and erase the important foothold
that the Viet Minh had
established in this place.
So Americans had no clue.
But these local actors
knew exactly symbolically
why they were doing that.
Okay, so this is the last
one and this gets back
to this base footprint,
this former military base,
which now is a very large industrial area,
industrial park.
And this centers on an
interview that I did
with former village head
on the village bordering
this space.
Some of the village lands,
especially the village cemetery,
was taken for Camp Eagle and
you actually have pictures
of U.S troops and their barracks situated
among Vietnamese tombs.
And the marines when they first used this
area called the Elzey tombstone,
because the landing zone
was set amid the tombstones.
Can you imagine what an
awful place that was,
to fight a war?
Anyway, this is about
what to do after the war.
And this is a discussion with this man,
Mr. Fog, and he said,
"the decision about what
vestiges to keep or let go
is complex when with many
parallels around the world."
"Landscapes are often
at the center of debates
involving veterans national history,
walls pockmarked by shrapnel
or metal skeletons of tanks
and down planes often
serve as focal points
for state guided reflection.
Proponents of memorialization
seek such ruin monuments
so that people will never forget.
While others seek to erase
these old word vestiges
to move on.
Communities are often
divided too in trying
to balance the desires of veterans
in the younger generation.
Mr. Fuller, the resident of Yatlay village
who fought with the 324th regiment.
That's one of those central
Vietnamese regiments
that moved north described
to me as shock after 1975
when the one time cityscape of Camp Eagle
"looking like New York.
Bright lights like crazy,
turned into an empty wasteland"
that you see here.
A native of the village
and a political officer,
he returned to the village
and hoped to preserve
parts of Camp Eagle as a museum.
While also salvaging
some of the metal siding
to build his house.
He went north to Hanoi for training.
And when he returned,
the tanks were all gone."
He said, "they cleared the hills
so that several years later,
there was nothing left.
Before when I looked from this place
out it was New York City,
but then they cleared it
and left it empty.
I returned in just farm my house
was an iron sighting house just built.
At that time, I resolved to
preserve one military tank
as a reminder" and you see this
in some Vietnamese villages,
the lone military tank.
"But then I went to Hanoi to study
and the people here they took it for scrap
removing everything.
I had intended to
preserve the American base
in Hamlet five, because I live near it.
I knew to preserve the base intact,
so that later our children
and people could come
and visit but they had taken
and had broken up everything.
The stuff the Americans left
was all destroyed."
And so this continues this
debate in Vietnamese society
about what to preserve and
how to preserve and of course,
it's very political.
And it's not only Vietnamese, of course,
Americans have very strong
feelings about these places too.
And for example one
American reporter traveled
to this site about a year after this film
was shot a guy named Craig Whitney
with the New York Times.
And in course he reports all that's left
is rubble and a few stones
and an American veteran
of the a hundred and first
airborne writes in the letter
to the editor, he says,
"I must respectfully disagree
with this observation
that only stones were left
where American basis had stood.
As a former noncommissioned officer
in the hundred and first who
spent a short but incredibly
intense part of my life
at Phu Bai in camp Eagle,
I know with certainty
that more was left there,
then a few stones.
Things like honor and comradeship
are former naivete,
and the blood of ourselves
and others in the sand.
For those of us who fought there Phu Bai
and Camp Eagle remains
something indelible.
A place in our minds and memories,
not just places on a map."
And so I leave you with that.
But I think it's important.
And I'm really interested
in our conversation today,
to think about militarization,
not simply in strict physical
or presentist terms,
but in these sort of
deeper layers and meanings.
- Thank you, David.
It's actually quite amazing how a turn
towards the landscape,
which in some ways seems
to be the most material
of all things,
actually brings you back to the immaterial
in such a complex way.
I see that running through
all of your pieces.
Because of time,
I wanna make sure we get questions
from the audience.
So before asking any of my own questions,
cause I can always follow up with you.
I'd like to see if
anyone from the audience
would like to start us off.
I see Michael G. Vann followed by Nam Kim.
So I'll start with Michael and then follow
with Nam Kim.
- Hi, good morning.
Can you see me or hear me?
- Yeah, we can hear you great, thanks.
- Okay, great panel.
And one of the things that came to mind
for me was repurposing of landscape
and also repurposing of memories.
And I know this is strongest for Vietnam,
but also happens in Cambodia in Laos,
as one of the panelists could say
something about repurposing
these landscape memories
of war for commercial tourism.
Particularly a Western market,
but also greater Asian tourism.
And thank you, great session.
- I'd be happy to
respond to that question.
I was just thinking
about this, this morning
and my planning for the session.
So there was a man that I studied with,
in Pforzheim which is one
of the most bombed places
on earth.
And his father, had been a soldier
during the American Vietnam War.
And his father had learned
how to dismantle bombs
during that conflict and
then had taught his son.
And now his son was working
in the illegal war scrap trade.
Because he knew where all
the battlefields were,
because of his dad's involvement,
going to those battlefields,
digging up ordnance and then selling them
on the black market.
And he also had a tourism company
where he would take people around on tours
of these old battlefields.
And I think that this account,
is really compelling
because it highlights for me
that the tourism, or at
least in my conversations
with this man, that the tourism was part
of a positive reclaiming of
a traumatic family history.
That he was able to
transform it into something
that helped him and his
kin to give it value.
That was the sense I had from this man
and my conversations with this man.
I mean, I'm sure there are
lots of super critical things
that one could say about war tourism,
but this was an example
in which it felt very positive.
- I could add just a little bit.
I went over so I'm gonna stay quiet,
except that one of the problems
in studying these places
is that the Vietnamese
militaries on the coast
is still very actively
engaged in some of them.
And the other problem
has to do with Vietnam's
ongoing stress with China
and its military relations
with the United States.
So and people that I talked
to, they were very careful
because they didn't really
know what were the political
valences of talking about
American War destruction,
given American arms
sales. (Jonathan laughing)
It's so political.
I think that's really stalled it.
- I don't have too much
to say about tourism
except it's interesting the
way that it for shortens
the historical processes.
In Cambodia, the Khmer
Rouge have only just left
PhnomPenh every single day.
It was just yesterday, right?
So tourists show up and
hang out at these cafes
and watch "Apocalypse Now" and right.
And I mean, it's
interesting to sort of ways
that these things distort history
as opposed to placing the places
that they are visiting within history.
So it's not something I've looked at,
but I did have a tourist
wander by this long house
that I was doing recording in one time.
So I think that they probably went home
with this wonderful story
of how they've gotten
so authentically into Cambodia
that they actually found
an anthropologist that worked
up in the hills, right.
I thought that was
quite a funny encounter.
So anyway.
- Thank you, everyone.
We're gonna turn to Nam
Kim who's an archeologist
from the University of Madison, Wisconsin,
also great experience in war landscapes,
but in the archaeological record.
Go ahead, Nam..
- Thank you.
Can you hear me?
- [Eric] Yes.
- Okay.
Many thanks, Eric and
the esteemed panelists
for a fascinating discussion.
I have a couple of comments,
and then a couple of questions
I'm hoping the panelists
might engage with.
Each of the panelists gives
us a very powerful reminder
about how the past and
purported ownership of that past
can be tied to physical pieces
of terrain and artifacts.
I found particularly
fascinating, Leah Zani's
example that piece of
motorcycle being presented
as a fragment of the war or of a war.
And it's reminiscent
of how many communities
produce counterfeit artifacts purportedly
from the ancient world
for various agendas,
and for profit.
I also appreciated David's assertion
about this presentis bias
and how we need to consider
the layers of warfare and conflict history
that interdigitate and become embedded
in these physical spaces.
My own work at the site of Goluan
in Vietnam illustrates how
conflict can leave these kinds
of scars on the environment
and on terrain over millennia.
Some of those ramparts
that were constructed
over 2,000 years ago,
during the 20th century,
soldiers dug slit trenches
and bunkers right into them.
And it gives us a kind of illustration
of how a space is militarized
through the course
of longer terms of history.
To relate it to these comments,
I'm interested to see how
our panelists might view
these kinds of ethical
questions about ownership
and presentation of that past,
given different stakeholders.
Who says what should be preserved,
how it should be preserved?
How we develop narratives
around those remains?
How these landscapes might
be considered sacred,
or significant as spaces of commemoration,
maybe even on a national level?
So essentially, in your experiences,
how do communities at both the local
and national levels work
together to determine
how these spaces are explained,
commemorated or exhibited?
Thank you.
- Well, I think, one thing that struck me
and talking about tourism is
that the really popular form
of tourism in these
villages, and in these sites
is actually a kind of funerary tourism.
You see it in the building
of ancestral shrines.
You see it in Nash state sponsored efforts
to recognize the dead and to
placate the wandering ghosts.
And I think this is really interesting
in a local context,
how different it might be,
say, in the American West,
it places like Wounded Knee,
and other sites like that.
Or the lynching sites in Mississippi,
where you have this extreme violence.
And I think that in Vietnam,
the discussions about commemoration,
both on the national and the local level,
are really much moving in
parallel with those discussions,
say, in the American West,
in the American South about
how do you respectfully,
preserve this kind of really
deep, horrible violence
without somehow reproducing
it or celebrating it,
or somehow demeaning it.
And that's very, very hard.
- I might just comment that this question
of what kinds of presentation
of the past are authorized
or in what ways might
the past that landscapes
be incorporated into these
practices of commemoration?
This is one of the sort of enduring themes
of much writing about
Southeast Asia and certainly
about the post war in the
mainland Southeast Asia.
It goes back to Ben
Anderson, for instance,
on official nationalisms, right,
this idea that there
are these nationalisms
that threaten the order,
and then there are these
efforts to impose official
versions of national pasts
that would be amenable
to projects of rule, I suppose.
And that shows up in sort of different way
in Hannah Quan's "Ghosts Of War," right.
That there are certain figures
from the past that are worthy
of national remembrance.
And then you have these
from below processes again,
that same font of memory,
that same font of looking
to the past for confirmation
for bolstering present day purposes,
can be sort of tapped into for a variety
of different sort of
approaches that is to say
that commemoration serves
different political agendas,
different agendas relating
to identity and belonging
in the present.
And that's the case for
landscapes as well, right.
So I think that's part of the reason
why I was trying to suggest
in my book, for instance,
that this notion of history from the hills
that this provides alternative
readings of the past.
And the fact that it's
accessible through the places
that one would walk through, right.
That one can actually
inhabit versions of the past
that speak to your present day reality.
I think that these are
the kinds of ways I think
that if we were to try
to look at your question
from the perspective of
the people who are living
in these landscapes
you might start getting
towards some of these kinds of approaches
to what those landscapes mean.
- I think that David and Jonathan
have done an excellent job
of responding to the
larger social implications
of Nam's question.
So I would like to respond to his comment
about interdigitation,
which is a great word. (Leah laughing)
And I talk about this in one
of the chapters in my book
about the gold mine.
Where these heavily
contaminated parts of Laos
are shared areas of
interests for archaeologists,
gold miners, and bomb clearance,
they share the same soil as
their zone of intervention.
And all three of these professional people
are kind of inter trained.
So for example, if the
gold mine that I studied,
the gold miners are trained to identify
possible explosive ordnance,
which they will dig up
with the gold, and also
archaeological evidence,
which they will also dig up with the gold.
And clearance technicians are also trained
to identify possible
archaeological artifacts,
and they treat them in much the same way
that they would treat a
bomb that it is subject
to the same kind of careful attention
and with the hands
carefully digging it up.
And so there's just a really
interesting interdigitation
of those three practices and
these contaminated areas.
And that this is not just an accident,
that the war has this ancillary effect
of preserving certain areas,
making it very difficult for people
to develop those zones.
And so they then become
sort of resource preserves
and that's one of the reasons
that Laos was targeted
by this multinational goldmine company
because it lost it's gold reserves
had been preserved by the war.
And it had been too dangerous to mine
in Laos for several decades.
And the same thing goes
for its archeological
artifacts as well.
So thinking about not only
how are these processes
interdigitated for practitioners
for a bomb clearance
technician who's also on the lookout
for archaeological artifacts,
but what historical processes lead to that
interdigitation over time,
and how militarism is one
of the forces that causes
these things to mix.
- Can I add one little piece to this.
Your comments Leah remind me
that there's also a
dimension to preservation
and excavation here on these sites.
That is a tension between
local communities in the state
and Vietnamese communities,
even patriotic communities who served
on the winning side, often
are in really strong tension
with the state.
Because state actors and
provincial level actors,
they have looked at other
examples of militarized spaces
like in Germany after World War Two.
And there's a certain global dialogue
about what to do about
so called ruined spaces,
both in terms of exhuming
bodies, commemorations,
how to appropriately do that,
the legal ramifications.
But also the sort of socio
economic transformations.
And, the interesting thing
about these base footprints
in Vietnam, is that the base footprints
are still there, they're
now industrial export zones.
The same sewer lines,
electric grids, streets,
and since they took the historic
1960s base architecture,
which sometimes was
sitting on earlier levels,
and they just kept it
as an industrial park.
So the villages never got the land back.
And so a lot of people in the villages
are still mad about the land
that was taken maybe
by the US Army in 1964
that's now occupied by the
provincial industrial park.
So there's some
interesting actors involved
and it's not the worst so
much that's so political
in central Vietnam, it's
the land and the land values
and the real estate, and who owns it,
and who benefits from it?
That is, in a sense the difficult thing
about exploring these places.
- You know I'll just jump in too
because there's been some comments
or people have been asking about the sort
of it's all rubble in ruins, right?
And I think it's just so interesting
how these objects from the
past as they break down
the narratives around them
also break down, right.
So that it's this sort of fragmenting,
as you watch the claims on the past
are sort of tied to the integrity
of the ruins, the landscapes of the past.
And so we see in David's example
where even the lone tank from the village
has been broken down into scrap
or you look at Leah's great discussions
of the ways that bombs are repurposed
and pulled apart, right.
And this really ties into
if any of you have read
this amazing book by Kim Fortuin
"Advocacy after BhoPal."
Her point is that the Indian government
was very interested to get
rid of the narrative, right.
Bhopal ended there was an end to the past
and what these ruins and rubble bring
on right in this sort
of, and Laura Stollerway
are sort of if you think
about some of the writing
about rubble and ruin recently.
That the breaking down of these pieces
of the past is accompanied by a process
of trying to de legitimize
claims made on the basis
of a shared experience
of the past, right.
That there's also a
community of Kim Fortuin
calls it a community of voicing the past
that is under attack from,
right those who are opposed
to whatever the political
goal of bringing out
that past is all about.
So it's just interesting to
see how there's connections
among all the different
pieces of the writings
I think your your pile
of books on your desk,
Eric was absolutely in
conversation with each other.
So I just find it interesting
to see that these themes
are cutting across
all of our discussions and questions.
- Thanks, everyone,
for these really many layered responses
to provocative questions.
I just wanna be mindful
of the time, it's 1:11.
We have until 1:20 before
we have to sign off.
So I'm gonna ask Aalim,
the doctoral candidate here at Yale,
to ask his question.
And then after that if
anyone has any questions
that they're afraid won't have time
to get in before the end of our session,
feel free to post them to the chat
because we're able to
save the chat session.
And then I'll communicate those
with the author's here today.
So let me turn it over to Al, go ahead Al.
- Thank you so much for the presentation.
Super, super fascinating.
I think I was wondering where the tension
on kind of building on a conversation
about the future.
So one way to look at it is the difference
between (indistinct) and Pattana.
So I think Leah, you wrote about that.
In Lao, there's this
tension between progress
and development.
So like Lao people feel sometimes
they don't have progress in the country.
So is this kind of nationalist dialogue?
So I'm wondering, like,
just kind of extending
this conversation on temporalities?
What is the kind of future
of looking at a certain sense
past the presentism?
And rich kind of historicism?
How do we reckon with what's going on?
And think there's talk about land value
and stuff like that?
Just yeah, I'd love to hear a little more
and maybe just potential speculation
is there something
distinctive about the forest
as opposed to the bomb landscape,
as opposed to the ruins
of the militarized zone sets?
Are they kind of different
and distinct from each other,
just kind of across the
different (Al laughing) yeah.
Thank you.
- I think what stood out
to be most in my research
about Pattana was that
just like, pretty much
everybody across the board didn't think
it was possible in Laos.
And I think that that's really
important ethnographically.
That seems to me to just be an incredibly
important evidence of like,
what widespread militarism
does to a people's own impression
of their possibility for a
future for a positive future
that people have, cause
I hear it all the time.
Like, oh, Laos doesn't have
the ability to do that.
They could do that in Thailand,
but we just can't do it
here. (Leah laughing)
And in talking to other people,
it was like a sort of catchphrase,
it was just so common to
hear comments like this,
like, "oh we're just
not capable of it here."
And, if I push someone like, okay, well,
why would it be possible
to have development
in Cambodia, but not in Laos.
People would give all
sorts of different answers.
But I think the thread that
runs through all of them
is this pervasive sense
that Laos is somehow
kind of like a bucket with a hole in it.
Like, it doesn't matter how much water
you put in the bucket,
it's all gonna fall out.
And that was not like the specific topic
of my study.
But I do think that that's
a really important feeling
that is definitely
related to being targeted
for a decade of covert warfare
of massive covert warfare
that has never been adequately
dealt with or acknowledged
by either the Lao government
or the American government.
- I'll attempt a response.
Yeah, I think part of
what I've tried to do
in my book is to lay out a method,
I'm not sure how successful it is.
But a method for understanding how people
in a place like Vietnam,
who have an understanding
of history, family history,
place history that goes
back at least 400 years,
if not an imagined history
that goes back longer.
How they experience conflict
like the Vietnam War
in the 60s.
And my point is, though maybe
I should have revised it
before I published the book
is that it's fundamentally
different from Americans
who are fighting after World
War Two, in these places.
Who see it as a technical spot,
thing on a map and improvise based city,
and then they're gone and they leave it,
except for the veterans who
still have the trauma of it.
But I think that the
way that people develop
the way development is understood
in Vietnam is a kind of
schizophrenic experience
in the sense.
And I'm thinking about vast
acacia augustifolia plantations
across the hills now,
it used to be barren and you could see
all the old base footprints.
Now they're all covered up with
pulp and paper plantations.
And the people who work in those places,
the people who work in
it, they know the history.
And when they're working
in those places, too,
they're very much somehow
working through that history
at the same time that
they're doing something new.
And I think there's an understanding
that part of your existence in a place
like anywhere in Indochina,
and most of Southeast Asia,
is in a sense, defined by reconciling
with this deeper past
and these deeper legacies
and the ghosts around you.
And the present sort of, churn
of earning a living working.
And it's just a really
different experience.
And that's what I'm trying
to convey in the book
in the sense that if you read this book,
you'll maybe get a little
better understanding
of how Vietnamese combatant
might have felt or somebody
in the Tet Offensive might
have felt, in this place.
It's not just one layer, but it's deeper.
- I guess I'll try to jump in.
It sounds like our Zoom is going
to blow up in three minutes.
Eric, is that correct. (Jonathan laughing)
- It won't blow up.
But we will have to close
the session at that time.
- Okay.
Well, this question of the
tension between progress
and development that Al raised.
When I set out to do field work,
there was this narrative in this sort
of development studies
literature that development,
as a project was future oriented, right?
So if you think about the book rule
of experts by Tim Mitchell, right,
Jim Scott's notion of high modernism,
the idea was that the
imaginations of planners
were all about imposing the will
of the state, on the people
through an imagination
of a technologically
superior, advanced future.
And the question that I actually
had going into the field
had to do with the ways in which arguments
about development in
Cambodia are really arguments
about the past, about
what the past authorizes.
And in that case, landscape,
certainly for the Jarai
and for many people in Cambodia,
the landscape that they live in
it provides the material
with which to make claims
on the past, right.
Because the world that we live in,
is formed by a traumatic
history of some sort.
A traumatic history that
has a hard time moving back
into the past because of
its utility in the present.
So that even today, the first line
of every development project document
in Cambodia has to do with
the rupture of history
that was created during
the Khmer Rouge period.
That's enough for me.
- Thanks, everyone.
We're basically at the
end of our time here.
And so I'll just bring this to a close.
I just wanna pause for a moment
and say what a wonderful
panel and discussion
this really was getting a lot
of messages through the chat
thanking us for organizing this.
But I really wanted on
behalf of the Council
of Southeast Asian Studies,
I wanna thank all of you
first for writing such wonderful,
eloquent and important books.
And also for answering
the call to come together
as a panel.
And I will suggest, I
think that further dialogue
amongst you certainly seems fruitful.
There's a lot of people who find
this discussion interesting.
So I hope that this small
panel could have been a spark
that starts a longer conversation.
Normally if this was held in New Haven,
we would all join each other
for lunch at Clark's diner.
But Clark's diner is
no longer in existence
because of the pandemic.
But because we're on virtual Zoom,
we can pretend that it still exists.
So, and next time you're
traveling through the Northeast,
I'd like to invite all of you out to lunch
to thank you for participating.
Anyhow, thank you very much.
And we'll see each other again soon.
- Bye.
Thank you, Eric and Chris,
for organizing and hosting.
- Yeah, thanks, everyone.
- Thank you, everybody.
Thanks, Erik.
- [Erik] Yeah, that's Jonathan and Leah.
- Yes, I'm so delighted
to have had this excuse
to read these two fabulous books.
- Likewise.
Okay, everyone click the end button.
So thanks again, and I'll be in touch
with all of you afterwards.
Thanks.
- Okay, thanks Erik.
Bye bye guys.
- [Erik] Bye everyone.